hey guys welcome back to brand-new be
we're back on foreigner and today we
have some interesting news it's not our
normal Thursday pretty weird of a
schedule don't really see you guys in
the weekend that often but we have some
interesting news about a leaked image
that came from Amazon so let's get into
that as always like the VP do enjoy a
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreign or that
being balanced changes hero updates
patch notes leaks all that good stuff
about for honored to keep everyone up to
date on what's happening within the game
so let's get started with today's video
so like I said there was a new leaked
image of Year 3 which in this case is
gonna be season 9 of for honor and I
just want to say two things one I will
not be showing this image as it may get
me copyright strikes so you can check
the image in the description if you're
on PC pop it up in another tab or if
you're on mobile look at the image study
it do all that [ __ ] write a paper about
it I don't care but then come back to
the video and we can discuss our
thoughts there and lastly I'm not going
to say that this leak is confirmed or it
is fake I just want to reiterate this is
not a confirmed for a fake leak for
season 9 this very well could be an
amazing Photoshop job from someone
trying to troll us or this could be
actual stuff of happening in season 9
there's no way to confirm this no way to
deny this we're just going to give our
thoughts on what is presented and so we
come off from there
but this leak was discovered because
Amazon had accidentally leaked this on
their website to purchase I assume this
has been taken down by now senses as
obviously not available but it was on
Amazon's page to purchase the for honor
year 3 pass going over the image we have
for weapons in the foreground possibly
symbolizing the four factions we have in
the game with the background of the sort
with the background of other swords and
a deserted land which looks pretty damn
cool I will admit going from the left to
the right we have a sword and a shield
lots of people within the foreigner
community have been wanting a hero with
this sword and shield so this could be
some very good news my bet is this is
going to be the night hero weapon since
the sword and shield would fit very well
with this faction nice-looking shield
with spikes on the side as well as a
good design in the middle so I'm very
excited to see what this character looks
like in-game if this is true of course
next is a simple straight sword most
likely going towards the woven because
the purple tassel kind of gives this
away as the wolven color is purple on
the logo really not much to talk about
this cool looking sort really excited to
see what this is but going on to the
third weapon this is the image we all
have seen from all the teasers and
whatnot it's a huge ass hammer this
hammer most possibly is
to be the viking weapon since I keep
getting in Norse mythology vibe from
this and the red ribbon on the handle
symbolizing the red color of the Vikings
if we're still going to be doing this
color thing but that's my personal
preference for this and the fourth one
looks like a very big two-headed axe
which by process of elimination should
go to the samurai personally if I had to
give my best to worst in terms of looks
I would definitely go with the samurai
I'm a huge sucker for two-handed axe
axes the notes are gonna be second with
the sword in the shield the [ __ ] with
the hammer and the balloon with the
straight sword since it's just a very
simple sword with a tassel on it
personally in terms of customization I
think the Knights because obviously when
you have a weapon there is three
different parts of the weapon you can
customize for the Knights I have a
feeling it's going to be the handle of
the weapon the sword of the weapon and
the shield that's very similar to I
believe what warlord has I could be
wrong though for the Wulin I have a
feeling it's gonna be just like a normal
Orochi or Ken say weapon you have the
guard the handle and the sword very
different stuff like that maybe the
tassel will change depending on the
handle if we're talking about the hammer
it'll most likely be the same thing
it'll be the big-ass hammer at the top
the handle in the middle and then the
little bottom part at the at the very
top at least within the image but it's
going to be at the bottom of the weapon
I don't really know what this is called
I believe it's called the pummel so that
is probably what's going to be
customized for the hammer and then for
the last one I actually think this is
going to be very similar to Berserker
you're going to be able to customize the
left side of the axe head and in the
right side of the axe head and the third
one is going to be the big handle so
that's going to be its own little thing
because as going off from the image both
heads of the axe are two different looks
so I'm assuming you're going to be able
to customize both sides make it look a
little different or match it whatever
you personally want to use I'm very
excited for this axe weapon I think
personally if this was if this is to be
confirmed true I will most likely vote
just based off the weapon I'll most
likely be going for the samurai
character with the two-headed axe just
for the possible customization ability
and hopefully this weapons gonna be
badass
hey guys let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and let me know what
you guys think about this image is it
real is it fake what guy are what
character are you going to main just
based off of these weapons anything
about this image or anything like that
I'd love to know in the comments below
yeah guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreign or that
being balanced changes hero updates
patch notes leaks
all that good stuff to get to be kept
up-to-date with for honor definitely
stay subscribe to the channel you should
definitely follow my Twitter and join
the discord that I have if you want to
be kept up to date when I upload videos
as well as turn on the bell for the
notifications all that type of [ __ ] hey
guys that'll be the end of the day today
hope you guys did enjoy have a great day
guys and peace out
[Music]
you